so far I really enjoy Marvel's midnight
Suns having now played about 15 hours at
the Tactical RPG which pulls inspiration
from the x-com games removing xcom's
frustrating percentage system which
caused even the most well-planned
strategies to have a chance of just not
working makes the turn-based Tactical
combat in Midnight Suns a lot more fun
and thanks to the deck building card
system Randomness still factors into the
equation creating a healthy bit of
challenge you can expect more words from
me regarding the actual gameplay of
midnight signs when the full review
embargo is up for now I want to briefly
touch on an aspect of midnight Suns we
haven't really had a chance to see a
whole lot of yet the writing and story
to recap in Midnight sunsi play as the
hunter prophesies to defeat your mother
Lilith and seal away her dark magic
forever you're assigned leadership of
the latest iteration of the midnight
Sons a team composed of superheroes with
powers that dabble in the Mystic and
Supernatural going out to face the
lowest demonic forces and the members of
Hydra she's enthralled Lilith's war on
Humanity attracts the attention of less
magically inclined Heroes as well and so
your efforts are also bolstered by
members of The Avengers and X-Men each
character features their own unique
abilities portrayed as cards within a
deck allowing to switch up your
strategies depending on who you bring on
a mission I wasn't expecting a story
quite so Action Hero Focus given the
namesake midnight Suns is pulling from
it's a bit by the numbers even by the
standards of superhero fiction so major
plot points can be seen coming from a
mile away and moments of grief or
tragedy aren't given adequate room to
Fester as the more wisecracking heroes
are quick to fill the Silence with jokes
to liven up the situation that's uh
Carol and Dr spooky over there here to
help so far it's keeping the game story
from being great but it's certainly not
bad by any stretch if you've watched any
of the team-oriented MCU movies you
already kind of know what you're getting
with midnight Suns this game feels more
like the mcu's lighthearted take on Age
of Ultron and less like the darker
midnight sense comic book series
between the major plot points midnight
sense allows you to explore optional
more personal Side Stories and it's in
those smaller interactions between the
Hunter and the individual members of
their team that the game manages to
squeeze out some incredible moments
building up your friendship with certain
Heroes and lots of additional cutscenes
and conversations with them many of
which culminate in heartwarming reveals
or devastating discoveries magic in
particular is one of the best written
characters in Midnight Suns and her
friendship Arc with the hunter which
sees the two Bond over their respective
struggles with their innate Darkness has
been my favorite part of the game thus
far in that same respect midnight sense
brings incredible characterizations to
the members of the midnight Suns Team
all of whom benefit from excellent voice
acting The Avengers and other
non-magical Heroes feel a bit boring in
comparison and maybe that's an
intentional choice to further highlight
the mystical and demonic personalities
that make up the Midnight Sun side of
the game from what I've seen so far
characters like Iron Man and Captain
America don't have very interesting
narrative arcs it's clear that the
Avengers as older Heroes have gone
through their fair share of growth prior
to the events of the game leaving less
room for Meaningful development with his
individuals or as members of a team in
comparison to the much younger members
of the midnight Suns most of whom
haven't worked with other superheroes
before it also doesn't help that the
actors voicing The Avengers and X-Men
seem to have been told to channel the
energy of their MCU counterparts as best
they could resulting in recognizable but
sub-optimal copies of characters we've
met before that said as of writing this
preview I have found that Captain
Marvel's Arc has begun to get quite
interesting and diverge a bit from what
we've seen of our character in the MCU
in recent comic book storylines which
may be a sign that the game is simply
taking a bit longer to turn its focus to
the development of the non-mystical
heroes we'll see how it all pans out by
the time of the review
overall my time with Midnight Sun so far
has been entertaining especially when
that time is spent focusing on the
members of the midnight Suns team like
Nico and Magic poems with other
characters don't extend to the combat as
everyone so far has proven to be fun to
play creating interesting team
combinations and potential deck building
strategies that keep each Mission fresh
and exciting here's hoping that keeps up